BACK ON ALL FRONTS AS DEMOCRATS
PUSH FORWARD IN THEIR
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
LET'S BREAK IT DOWN FOR A PARADE
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOUBLING DOWN ON
HIS CALLS TO IDENTIFY THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
SUBPOENAS HAVE BEEN ISSUED FOR
RUDY GIULIANI AND MIKE POMPEO.
SECRETARY OF STATE CALLING
SUBPOENAS AND ATTEMPT TO QUOTE
BULLY AND INTIMIDATE
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS.
LAST NIGHT, RUDY TOOK ON BIDEN.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
SILENCING ME?
BECAUSE I'M NOT MAKING ANY
POINTS?
THEY ARE SILENCING ME BECAUSE I
SHOWED UP WITH AN AFFIDAVIT
YESTERDAY AND ON ACCUSER WHO IS
WILLING TO STAND UP AND POINT
THE FINGER AT JOE BIDEN AND SETY
THE FINGER AT JOE BIDEN AND SETU
ARE A CROOK.
AND I HAVE THE PROOF AND I HAVE
THE DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT THE C
THE DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT THE R
THE DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT THE O
THE DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT THE A
THE DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT THE I
THE DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT THE N
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE WITNESSES
WHERE HE CAME FROM AND THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO ESCAPE THIS.
>> Jesse: THE STORY DEMOCRATS
WON'T TELL YOU ABOUT TODAY IS
JOE BIDEN CAUGHT LYING ABOUT HIS
KNOWLEDGE OF HIS SON'S SHADY
FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS NEWLY
UNEARTHED PHOTO OF JOE AND
HUNTER BIDEN'S PLAYING GOLF WITH
A KEY UKRAINIAN GAS EXECUTIVE
BACK IN 2014.
REMEMBER WHEN JOE WENT BALLISTIC
WHEN SAID HE HAD NEVER SPOKEN TO
HIS SON ABOUT THOSE DEALINGS?
>> I HAVE NEVER SPOKEN TO MY SON
ABOUT THAT.
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW.
I KNOW TRUMP DESERVES TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
HE IS VIOLATING EVERY BASIC NORM
OF A PRESIDENT.
YOU SHOULD BE ASKING HIM THE
QUESTION, WHY IS HE ON THE PHONE
WITH A FOREIGN LEADER TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE A FOREIGN LEADER?
>> Jesse: IT'S BEEN TWO WEEKS
SINCE THE STORY BROKE.
IT FEELS LIKE A YEAR.
SINCE PETER DOOCY ASKED THAT
POINT IN QUESTION, DO YOU TALK
TO HER SON ABOUT HIS BUSINESS
DEALING?
'S WE KNOW HE LIED WHEN HE SAID
HE DOESN'T AND WE KNOW HE WARNED
PETER DON'T ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS AND I THINK THE MEDIA
HAS LISTENED BECAUSE THE MEDIA
HAS NOT ASKED JOE BIDEN A DIRECT
QUESTION ABOUT ALL OF THIS AND
NOT ONLY THAT, THE GUY AT THE
EPICENTER OF THIS WHOLE THING,
HIS SON, HUNTER, WHERE IS
HUNTER?
THEY HAVEN'T FOUND HUNTER
ANYWHERE.
BEFORE IT'S INTERESTING THE
APPROACHES PRAY THERE WAS A
PIECE TODAY IN THE ATLANTIC
COMPARING THE IMPEACHMENT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
SUGGESTION WAS THAT CLINTON CAN
HANDLE THAT MUCH BETTER.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT TWO ARE
QUITE COMPARABLE.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS CLINTON HAD GOING FOR HIM
WAS THAT THE MEDIA WAS NOT
HELPING BASICALLY --
NOT TRYING TO HARM HIM BUT THE
PRESIDENTS REALIZING HIS ALLIES
ARE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
THAT HIS APPROACH HAS ALWAYS
BEEN TO PUSH AND PUSH AND PUSH.
THE BIDEN APPROACH THOUGH ON ALL
OF THIS HAS BEEN VERY CURIOUS TO
ME.
I DON'T KNOW -- GO BEYOND SEEING
THE PICTURE, I DON'T KNOW THAT
HE SAYS HE DIDN'T TALK TO HIS
SON ABOUT IT.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THEM BUT
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
TESTIFY AT SOME POINT.
>> Jesse: WHEN YOU PLAY GOLF
WITH THE FOREIGN MINISTER, YOUR
SON JUST SO HAPPENS TO BE
APPOINTED TO THE SAME GAS
COMPANY IN UKRAINE, HOW DO YOU
GUYS KNOW EACH OTHER?
THE FATHER, JOE BIDEN, DOING
BUSINESS IN UKRAINE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
WEATHER.
COME ON.
DON'T BE SILLY.
>> BUD SELIG THING I KNOW ABOUT
GOLF IS HANDICAPPING BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT?
IT'S BETTER THAN TALKING ABOUT
THIS WHICH IS THE TRANSCRIPTS.
WHICH IS THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
COMPLAINTS.
DONALD TRUMP WANTS US TO TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING BUT THIS AND THIS
IS WHAT HAS GOTTEN HIM IN HOT
WATER.
>> Jesse: IS THAT THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE COMPLAINT?
>> THIS IS THE --
THIS IS THE VERSION THAT THEY
WANT US TO SEE.
IT JOE BIDEN WORKS WITH THE E.U.
AND OTHERS COULD WE KNOW IT
JOE BIDEN DID.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS BEEN NO
EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER OF
CORRUPTION.
I WENT BACK BECAUSE --
KNOLL BECAUSE BECAUSE YOU
INSPIRED ME TO READ THE ENTIRE
300 PAGES OF INFORMATION OUT
THERE AND WHAT I CAME UP WITH --
YOU KNOW, LOOK.
I'M A VERY GOOD READ.
I EVEN PUT ON MY CBS PURCHASE
GLASSES SO I WAS REALLY EXACT.
AND --
$25.
SO HERE IT IS.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO
TREAT CONGRESS AS A BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION NEEDS
TO COOPERATE WITH CONGRESS AND
HELP THEM GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS SO THAT THIS SAGA WILL BE
OVER WITH.
A SPIN ON ONE OF THE THINGS,
JEDEDIAH, THAT THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IS THE LAST ELECTION AND HOW
DOES COLLUSION HOAX BEGAN IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND ILHAN OMAR HAS
BEEN DIRECTED TO TALK TO THE
UKRAINIANS, TO THE ITALIANS, TO
THE BRITISH AND TO THE
AUSTRALIANS AND THE MEDIA IS
PANICKING NOW.
>> Jedediah: THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH THAT.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG AT ALL.
I KNOW POMPEO WAS ON THE CALL
AND THAT SUCH BREAKING NEWS
BRIDWELL, WE WERE BASICALLY ON
THE CALL TOO BECAUSE THE
TRANSCRIPT IS IN FRONT OF US AND
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID AND
THERE'S NO QUID PRO QUO THERE.
I THINK JOE BIDEN IS IN TROUBLE.
I THINK HE IS IN SERIOUS
TROUBLE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WAS DOING A
VERY BAD JOB ON THE DEBATE
STAGE.
HE WAS UNDERPERFORMING TO SAY
THE LEAST.
MANY PEOPLE WERE GETTING
NERVOUS.
HE SAW ELIZABETH WARREN ARRIVING
AT THE POLLS AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY ATTEMPT TO MAKE THIS ABOUT
TRUMP, JOE BIDEN AND HIS
DEALINGS WITH HIS SON AND WHAT
HE DID WITH RESPECT TO THAT
PROSECUTOR THAT HE WANTS TO GET
FIRED AND THAT TAPE THAT SHOWED
UP WITH HIM WITHHOLDING MONEY
COMES AT ALL IMPLICATES HIM IN
THIS AND THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
LONG BEFORE AT MANY OF THOSE
DONORS WHO HAD BIDEN'S BACK
SAYING HE WAS MOST ELECTABLE ARE
GOING TO PULL BACK SAYING THIS
GUY HAD TOO MUCH BAGGAGE AND HE
IS IMPLICATED IN THIS AND THIS
DOES NOT LOOK GOOD FOR HIM AND
EVEN IF YOU CAN'T STAND
PRESIDENT TRUMP YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT A CALL AND SAY I
DON'T SEE ANY IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE HERE.
BE REALISTIC ABOUT IT AND SAY
THAT JOE BIDEN --    --
THIS WAS NOT ALL KNOWN TO THE
PUBLIC BY THE WAY.
THERE WAS REPORTS ON IT, SOME
PEOPLE KNEW ABOUT THIS, NOT
EVERYBODY KNEW ABOUT IT FOR THIS
IS NOT GOING TO HELP THEM IN
2020.
>> BUT THE REPORTS WERE STILL A
TRASH CAN AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WRITE IT ON FIRE.
I'M NOT HERE TO --
>> Jedediah: THEY WERE SAYING
THAT THEY HAD A PROBLEM WITH
POTENTIAL QUID PRO QUO WHEN IT
CAME TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN IS ON RECORD SAYING
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET THE
MONEY.
THAT IS HIM SPEAKING IN HIS OWN
WORDS.
BEFORE I ROGNIZEA
POWER AND LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
OTHERS BELIEVE JOE BIDEN DID
SOMETHING WRONG.
EXPLAIN THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF HYPE --
THERE'S A LOT OF HYPE.
OF COURSE I WON'T SPEAK WITH THE
AUTHORITY OF GOD BUT GREG --
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN IS GOING
TO HAVE TO SUPPORT HIS
FUND-RAISING NUMBERS VERY SOON
AND THE PRESIDENT AND HIS COMMIT
AND THE PRESIDENT AND HIS COMMIE
JUST CAME OUT WITH A
WHOPPING HUNDRED $25 MILLION
THIRD-QUARTER HOLE.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S A LOT
OF MONEY.
A LOT OF CRUMBS.
I AM FOCUSING ON WHAT THE MEDIA
IS DOING RIGHT NOW AND WHAT THEY
ARE DOING IS SHAPING PUBLIC
OPINION.
TO SAY A WEEK AND A HALF AGO
THAT NOBODY CARED ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT, IT WAS A BAD IDEA
TO IMPEACH, THOSE NUMBERS HAVE
SIFTED DRAMATICALLY WHICH IS THE
MEDIA REPORTING THAT IT'S
SHIFTING DRAMATICALLY.
SO WHO'S BEEN PUSHING THOSE
BUTTONS AND PULLING THE STRINGS?
THE SAME MEDIA REPORTING THIS.
THE STORY HASN'T CHANGED AT ALL.
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT REPORTING,
IT'S ABOUT REPETITION.
THE STORY IS SO SMALL BUT WAS
EVEN SMALLER IS THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE GENERATING IT.
I HAVE A THEORY THAT 1,000
PEOPLE ARE GENERATE THIS STORY
STORY.
500 PEOPLE ARE DICTATING WHAT
333 --
350 MILLION PEOPLE ARE LISTENING
TO RAIN OUT HERE THIS IS A SLASH
FIGHT IN THE TINIEST KIDDIE POOL
OF INFLUENCERS AND IT'S A
SELF-PERPETUATING MEDIA MACHINE
THAT MUST GENERATE LOUDER AND
LOUDER NOISE AS WE REALIZE HOW
LITTLE --
I'LL EVEN GO THAT WAY WITH
BIDEN.
THERE IS NO THERE.
BUT THIS STORY ITSELF IS SO
SMALL AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GENERATING THIS SOUND IS SO
SMALL --
I MEAN WE ARE BEING SOLD A BILL
OF GOODS.
REMEMBER THE GOOD OLD DAYS WHEN
SCANDALS WERE SCANDALOUS?
WATERGATE, THIS IS SCANDAL
IMPERSONATION.
I'M INSULTED THAT I'M WASTING MY
TIME LISTENING TO THIS.
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU WERE A KID
AND HE WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT AND YOU THOUGHT THERE
WAS A MONSTER IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE YOUR ROOM AND IT WAS JUST
CLOSE ON A CHAIR --
THIS IS CLOSE ON A CHAIR.
SHE LAST POINT ABOUT THE MONEY,
THIS HELPS TRUMP BECAUSE IT
ANGERS THE PUBLIC BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THAT THEY ARE BEING
PULLED INTO A FALSE DRAMA.
YOU HAVE THE CITED GROUP OF
PEOPLE HAVING A MONTE MENTAL
EFFECT ON AN ENTIRE COUNTRY AND